so i really like exercises that are
unassuming they look really simple but
they're actually brilliant in terms of
the
huge variety of different benefits they
offer there are a few exercises that
look more simple but offer
more incredible depth than the 100 up or
high knees
essentially jogging on the spot it seems
almost too simple to be
worth anything but in fact it can help
you to prevent injuries it can improve
your running form
it has tons of athletic benefits you can
do it anywhere and it's so versatile it
could be combined with
all kinds of other moves in a wide
variety of different ways so what's the
100 up essentially it's running on the
spot
except you're raising your knees a
little bit higher than you normally
would
there are two variations the 100 minor
and the 100 up major the minor version
is a much slower exercise where you
carefully raise each leg and then place
it back down before lifting the other
and the major is slightly faster so i'll
show you them side by side here is the
minor
and the major
and the third variant is high knees
where you're going to be bringing the
knees up
much higher and at the same time you're
going to be completely minimizing the
ground contact time making a more
plyometric exercise and at some points
you should have both feet raised off the
ground that looks like this
so of course the first and obvious
reason that a lot of people like the 100
up or high knees
is just that it's a good way to burn
calories that doesn't require a lot of
space
and that literally anybody can do it's
like running in that it's a full body
movement
and you're in continuous motion and this
means that you're going to burn
a fair amount of calories it's a very
efficient way to do that
of course the problem with running is
you need a big open space to run around
in
and if it's raining or if you just don't
fancy it it can be pretty hard dragging
yourself
out the door to do that the hundreds up
is something you can do in front of the
television and in that regard it's very
similar to skipping
except the difference here is that you
don't need a rope which can smash things
in your living room and trust me i'm
speaking from experience you can make
the 100 up even more of a
full body workout by the way by also
holding dumbbells at the same time
as you're running and that's going to
work the upper body a little bit more if
you're doing high knees
it's like sprinting and you can burn the
equivalent number of calories this way
the high knees variant is particularly
good if you want something for a high
intensity interval training program or
if you want to use it as part of a
circuit alongside things like push-ups
and body weight
moves so yeah fantastic for burning
calories
if you're doing the minor version this
is pretty much the equivalent of going
for a
gentle walk and if you're doing the
major version it's like a light jog and
this is actually something that a lot of
people interested in strength training
in particular i need to consider more
this is a really great form of low
intensity cardio of course you have
things like burpees that you can use or
kettlebell swings
at home if you want to burn calories
quickly but they're all pretty intensive
and high impact and they aren't suitable
for everyone 100 ups or just jugging on
the spot are perfect
because they allow you to burn calories
in a way that's really low impact and
really easy
but at the same time this kind of low
intensity very low intensity cardio
is actually really good for all sorts of
things and if you're someone who builds
a lot of strength
you can use this as a great way to
enhance your recovery going for walks
going for light jogs and doing the 100
up
all help to increase blood flow and
circulation around the body this can
actually accelerate healing and
reduce doms and help you to grow back
thicker and stronger after a big workout
the day before what's more is that in
the long term this kind of exercise can
strengthen the heart
it can improve your cumax which means
you'll always be delivering more blood
around your body and it can even improve
capillarization
that means you'll form new blood vessels
supplying the muscles with blood
so they get more energy and more
nutrients both during training
and during recovery so you'll be able to
train for longer and you'll recover
faster
and it'll even accelerate the removal of
waste products that build up in the
muscles
and that lead to fatigue so don't think
that because you're this high caliber
athlete you don't need
really low intensity cardio what we
really want to be trying to do is
getting exercise that fits everywhere on
the spectrum
and just standing in front of tv and
doing some slow high knees
is a great way to just burn a few
calories get the blood circulating
it's also a fantastic option for
incidental training you guys know i like
to break my training up throughout the
day
to train whenever the opportunity
presents itself you can use this in
front of the tv like i say you can get
up and do a few whilst your computer's
loading or
just for a 10 minute stint you can even
use this in the bank whilst you're in a
queue
although you probably will get some
weird looks and not even i am probably
weird enough to try that one out
of course the minor 100 up is also
fantastic for anyone who has hip issues
hip stability issues
who's recovering from injury especially
a running related injury
this is a great way to strengthen those
muscles get yourself back
into moving but without having to go for
an actual run and potentially making
matters worse
if you struggle with balance you can
even hold on to a wall to begin with
and just go through the motion really
slowly where the 100 up really excels as
a means to improve your running form
and thereby to improve your athletic
performance so the 100
was actually developed by walter george
who was a
runner and he used this allegedly to
train himself to become
a much better runner just in his down
time and he went on to become highly
decorated
you might be looking at the hundred up
or the high knees and thinking that it
can't possibly translate that well to
running because the biomechanics are so
different because you're
upright instead of leaning forwards
apart from anything else but actually if
you think about it running on a
treadmill has many of the same problems
when you're on a treadmill the
the tracks move underneath you so you
don't actually have to push yourself
forwards in the way that you normally
would
what running on the spot like this does
do is that it teaches you to keep your
core
upright and engaged when you're running
gives you opportunity to practice
keeping the rest of you nice and relaxed
try relaxing the face to encourage the
rest of your body to stay loose this can
reduce the chance of injury
improve your speed and certainly your
endurance because it makes you more
efficient
and at the same time this lets you
practice your hip stability as you
transfer weight from one leg to the
other one
over time the aim is to place the foot
back down exactly where you lifted it up
from
watching someone perform this is a great
way to spot any
deficits and because you're doing this
for a long duration in a safe
environment
you can start to feel this become more
difficult as you're doing this try and
focus on where you're distributing your
weight on your foot is it
tilting slightly inwards or outwards or
is it landing nice and evenly
you can then use this as a way to
improve your form as your strength
endurance starts to wane because that's
when
injuries happen when you've been running
a long time your core starts to tire
your technique starts to suffer and then
something gets pulled or twisted
so by using 100 up you're just
strengthening yourself and becoming more
confident and stable
in those positions and this does
translate to better performance when you
perform the high knees
that transfers even greater because now
you're able to practice pushing your
feet off the ground
extremely quickly and exploding as a
plyometric movement you're practicing
using the myotic stretch response
and returning energy to the ground as
fast as possible which of course
has great transfer to sprinting in
particular when you do this you're
strengthening your
tendons and improving ankle stiffness so
normally when you sprint
your calf is actually not as involved or
doesn't use as much of a concentric
contraction
as you might think during plantar
flexion so it's not so much about your
calf
moving your foot rather your calf
maintains an isometric hold
and then it's the tendon that is now
pulled taut and it returns that energy
and springs you back across the track
and that is why ankle stiffness is so
important for athletes and like the
burpee one other thing i really like
about
high knees and hundred ups is that you
can combine them with all kinds of other
exercises
and all kinds of variations if you want
to gain even greater benefits from them
and create a kind of like athletic flow
so for instance you can combine them
obviously with burpees
perform high knees or 100 ups in between
each repetition
alternatively you can just combine high
knees with push-ups do a few high knees
drop to the ground do some push-ups
get back up and do high knees and this
is really great for people who want the
benefits of the burpee
but who don't like that jumping motion
which can be a bit hard on your back if
you have
any existing problems there at the same
time you can combine it with different
kinds of
footwork so for instance you can do it
with 45 degree bounds
so you can split it up with skater hops
gator hops are in the frontal plane
moving side to side
and so this is a great way to practice
that and this can strengthen the
it band and prevent pain and injury
there because a lot of the problems we
get
are from repetitive use of a single
movement in a single plane whereas if we
mix things up and move about then we can
keep the body strong in all positions
and ready for anything
and if you're more interested in
strength and strength endurance then one
really cool variation you can use is you
can grab
two kettlebells hold on either hand or
grab one kettlebell and hold it in one
hand
and then you can perform the 100 up
almost like a farmer's walk so it's a
loaded 100 up this is a really cool way
to
get many of the same benefits as a
farmer's walk or loaded carry
you're strengthening the traps you
should maintain a very slight
raise in the traps you'll strengthen the
grip of course
at the same time you're building even
more core strength even more hip
stability
particularly if you place the weight
just on one side make sure to train
both sides the same of course because
now you're using anti-lateral flexion to
prevent yourself
bending that way this burns more
calories builds a lot of
usable strength and it's something again
you can do anywhere
i thought maybe i invented this movement
but then i posted it on instagram and
those people were like yeah i do those
too so
let's say we all invented it so yeah in
a nutshell that's why i love the 100 up
hit something you can do anywhere it's
an extremely portable movement
it's suitable for every single level and
it can be used to
burn calories improve fitness encourage
recovery
it can enhance athletic performance by
improving your explosiveness and your
tendon hysteresis all these things the
100 up
is extremely underrated and especially
when you combine it with other movements
and mess around with what you can do
with it let me know what you think in
the comments down below do you use the
100 up or
high knees are you going to now what
other deceptively simple exercises do
you know
i shared another one recently on my blog
thebioneer.com and that was the
reverse plank so if you want to know why
i think that's awesome
then you can check out that article as
well if you did find this useful then
please leave a like and share around
comment down below and subscribe all
those things help me out
immensely and i'd just like to take this
opportunity as well to thank you for all
your support
on that elbow video that i had to
re-upload so many of you
commented for the algorithm and it
helped out immensely actually meant that
the
video didn't suffer that much in terms
of view count in the end which is
obviously
fantastic so thank you so much guys that
was humbling
and just really cool of you all to do um
have some other exciting news for the
channel i've recently made the decision
to go full time here on the bioneer
i packed in my freelance writing a few
months back and
i'm now stepping down from my contractor
position at android authority as well
which is bittersweet because
those guys are really cool and i have
some really great memories and had loads
of cool opportunities
but you know running the bioneer
full-time has been a
huge ambition of mine pretty much since
i left university which was like
over 10 years ago now so i can't believe
it's finally happening
and i'm super excited i've got some like
real-life stuff going on at the moment
things haven't been that normal
but once that gets back to normal and
once i've worked my notice you can
expect
more content more interactivity and big
announcements here at the bioneer so
stay tuned for all that and
thank you guys so much because again
none of this would have been possible
without
you all and i can't believe it's
happened to be quite honest so
thanks for enjoying the content and i
hope you'll stick around for what comes
next
final little bit of news is that i am
going to be doing a new bat caves and
home gym home office video soon so if
you'd like to share pictures
and videos of your own home batcave your
own home offices and home gyms
then please head over to the facebook
page the link will be in the description
down below
there you'll find a post you can share
your images on there members of the
patreon only
bioneer group on facebook have already
shared theirs and
there's some really cool stuff you guys
have those will definitely be getting
your face and i'll share as many of
yours as possible in that video
as well and we can inspire each other to
create more awesome spaces
for training and working so yeah look
forward to that one
and one final bit of news i finally had
a haircut
if you like training in a functional
manner with a real world transfer
then check out my ebook and training
program super functional training
this is a program designed to build
everything from ability and strength
to agility and even brain power there's
a link in the description down below and
it's on discount right now while we're
all struggling with a pandemic you could
alternatively read my print book
functional training and beyond this is a
detailed introduction to functional
training
and what the human body is capable of
aimed at the general population
so yeah guys thanks so much for
everything and i'll see you next time
bye for now